Kris Jenner admits she's in denial about
OJ Simpson's parole Oh J's going up for
parole again I know it scares the death
out of me
[Music]
it's been over five months since the
former NFL star was granted parole after
serving nearly nine years behind bars
for a 2007 kidnapping and armed robbery
in Las Vegas on Sunday's episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Chris
sat down for lunch with her friend Faye
Resnick who rose to fame when she
co-authored a book in 1994 about her
late friend Oh J Simpson's wife Nicole
Brown Simpson and opened up about him
getting out of jail
hojae's going up for parole again I know
it scares the death out of me
I've been having nightmares about that
Oh Jay was released from prison in
October but the 62 year olds whose late
husband Robert Kardashian was a friend
of the athlete and served as one of his
defense attorneys during his murder
trial admitted she was having a hard
time processing OJ's then upcoming
parole hearing this is so good when it
takes us how do you go from that
conversation to this is so good because
I'm in denial obviously
[Music]
you